>>> WORLD LEADERS ARE PAYING
TRIBUTE TO THE FORMER SOUTH
AFRICAN PRESIDENT WHO HELPED HIS
COUNTRY END APARTHEID AND
TRANSITION TO DEMOCRACY.
FW DE KLERK DIED AT THE AGE OF
85 HE'S PRAISING HIM FOR OPENING
THE DOOR TO FULL DEMOCRACY.
SOME SAID THIS.
HE TOOK THE COURAGEOUS DECISION
TO UNBAN POLITICAL PARTIES,
RELEASE POLITICAL PRISONERS AND
ENTER INTO NEGOTIATIONS WITH A
LIBERATION MOVEMENT.
BUT HE WAS A DEEPLY DIVISIVE
FIGURE WHO BENEFITTED FROM THE
REPRESSIVE SYSTEM THAT HE HELPED
ENFORCE.
THE ARCHBISHOP HAD THIS TO SAY
ABOUT THE FORMER LEADER.
WHILE HE PLAYED A VITAL ROLE, HE
WAS NEVER ABLE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE FULL EXTENT OF APARTHEID'S
EVIL.
IN A PRE-RECORDED MESSAGE,
HERE'S WHAT HE HIMSELF SAID
ABOUT HIS CHANGE OF HEART.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> I WITHOUT QUALIFICATION
APOLOGIZE FOR THE PAIN AND THE
HURT AND THE INDIGNITY AND THE
DAMAGE THAT APARTHEID HAS DONE
IN SOUTH AFRICA.
>> CNN'S DAVID KENZ McKENZIE
TAKES A LOOK AT THE LEGACY OF
THE LAST WHITE PRESIDENT.
>> HE HELPED END GENERATIONS OF
WHITE MINORITY RULE IN SOUTH
AFRICA.
>> A NEW A DEMOCRATIC IS
FORESEEN WITH PULL PULL
POLITICAL RIGHTS FOR SOUTH
AFRICANS.
>> Reporter: EARLIER IN HIS
CAREER THERE WAS LITTLE HINT OF
ANYTHING REVOLUTIONARY.
A DEEPLY CONSERVATIVE DECLERK
ROSE THROUGH THE RANKS DURING
THE MOST DRACONIAN PERIODS OF
APARTHEID RULE.
THEN PRESIDENT IN 1990.
>> THE GOVERNMENT HAS TAKEN A
FIRM DECISION TO RELEASE MR.
MANDELA.
>> WE LEARNED IT IN A PLACE
WHICH WAS MODERNLY UNJUSTIFIABLE
AND I CAME TO THE REALIZATION I
CANNOT BUILD A SECURITY OF MY
PEOPLE ON THE BASIS OF INJUSTICE
TOWARDS A MAJORITY OF ALL THE
PEOPLE.
>> SOME OF HIS PEOPLE CALLED THE
CLERK A TRAITOR FOR RELEASING
NELSON MANDELA.
BUT THE DEMOCRATIC TRANSITION
HELPED STAVE WHAT MANY SAW AS
INEVITABLE CIVIL WAR.
>> IT WAS ONLY IN SOUTH AFRICA
WHEN WE NEGOTIATE AND WHEN
MANDELA SAID I WILL TRY TO
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERNS.
YOU CANNOT DIFFUSE TENSION
UNLESS THE PARTIES TO THE
CONFLICT START TALKING TO EACH
OTHER.
>> DELAWARE CLERK WOULD WIN THE
PEACE PRIZE.
BUT THE LAST WHITE PRESIDENT OF
SOUTH AFRICA ONCE CALLED A PAR
TIDE A DEVELOPMENTAL POLICY.
EARLY 2R50ULY REPUDIATING IT
AFTER AN OUTCRY.
SOME SOUTH AFRICANS FELT THAT HE
HAD LITTLE MORAL AUTHORITY TO
CRITICIZE A DEMOCRATICALLY
ELECTED GOVERNMENT AS HE
FREQUENTLY DID.
OVER THE YEARS, DE KLERK
DEVELOPED A MUTUAL RESPECT, EVEN
FRIENDSHIP, A SIM BILLION THAT
DE KLERK SAID REPRESENTED WHAT
COULD BE POSSIBLE IN A COUNTRY
WITH SUCH A PAINFUL PAST.
>> MY NEXT GUEST IS THE AUTHOR
OF "THE BATTLE FOR THE SOUL OF
THE ANC."
HE JOINS ME NOW FROM
JOHANNSBURG.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
I KNOW YOU HEARD THAT LAST
MESSAGE, THAT RECORDED MESSAGE
OF HER FRAIL DE KLERK,
APOLOGIZING FOR THE PAIN, THE
HURT AND THE INDIGNITY CAUSED BY
APARTHEID.
FOR MANY THAT APOLOGY SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED A FEW DECADES AGO.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
>> WHEN I HEARD THAT APOLOGY,
MANY BLACK SOUTH AFRICANS HAVE
BEEN TO APOLOGIZE, TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HURT OF BLACK
SOUTH AFRICANS.
I THINK ON HIS DEATH BED, IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT
ACKNOWLEDGMENT.
BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN DIFFICULT TO
RECONCILE BLACK AND WHITE SOUTH
AFRICANS.
THEY WOULD BE VERY BITTERER THAT
THEY ARE SUFFERING TSHL THINGS
THAT HAPPEN TO THEM DURING A PAR
TIDE AND HAVE NOT BEEN
ACKNOWLEDGED OFFICIALLY BY DE
KLERK, THE LAST WHITE PRESIDENT
OF SOUTH AFRICA.
>> I KNOW IT MUST BE EMOTIONAL.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT HIS DEATH
AND HIS LEGACY SYMBOLIZE FOR
BLACK SOUTH AFRICANS THAT LIVED
UNDER HIS RULE AT THE TIME AND
ALSO HIS PREDECESSOR, THE
ATROCITIES THAT OCCURRED DURING
APARTHEID AND WHAT DE KLERK
SYMBOLIZES.
>> I THINK DE KLERK HAS TO ACT
WHEN HE MADE THAT DECISION TO
END FORMAL APARTHEID AND THE A
ACTIVISTS, IT REALLY WAS
IMPORTANT.
IT DID SECURE HIS LEGACY FOR ALL
TIME.
IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT.
WHAT IT DID, THAT PREVENTED
SOUTH AFRICA PLUNGING INTO A
CIVIL WAR AND BREAKING DOWN.
SO IT WAS REALLY IMPORTANT.
AND YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
CONTEXT OF THE LATE 1980s.
SOUTH AFRICA, IT WAS NOT EASY
FOR HIM BECAUSE THE WHITE
COMMUNITY WAS ALSO DIVIDED.
WHAT MANY OF THEM WERE ABOUT
ENDING APARTHEID AND IT TAKES A
VERY COURAGEOUS DECISION TO DO
THAT.
AND OF COURSE, BEFORE HIM,
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS THIS THEIR
PEACE OPEN UP A PLACE FOR HIM TO
MAKE THE DECISION.
AND I THINK HE WILL RANK UP
THERE.
I THINK WHEN HE ENDED COMMUNIST
RULE, I THINK THEY WOULD BE
SIMILARLY IN HISTORY SECURED.
>> COULD YOU TAKE ME THRUGH
WHAT JOINT INTERACTION HAS BEEN
AND HOW MANY TIMES PEOPLE HAVE
ASKED DE KLERK IN THE 35ST TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT APARTHEID WAS A
CRIME AGAINST HUMANITY AND HE
ALWAYS PUSHED BACK.
WE KNOW IT WAS A DIFFICULT TIME.
AS YOU SAY, HERE'S A WHITE
CONSERVATIVE MAN THAT HAD SO
MUCH PRESSURE FROM HIS PARTY,
FROM IT HIS IDEOLOGIES, FROM THE
MOMENT HE WAS BORN, TO TRY TO BE
THE AGENT OF CHANGE IN A VERY
POLARIZED COUNTRY.
>> I INTERACTED WITH HIM A FEW
YEARS AGO BECAUSE I PARTICIPATED
IN A DOCUMENTARY OF HIS LIFE.
AND THEY ENGAGED WITH HIM ABOUT
ASKING WHY DOESN'T HE APOLOGIZE
BECAUSE AN APOLOGY WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR BLACK SOUTH
AFRICANS.
THE ACKNOWLEDGMENT.
AN APOLOGY FOR ME WOULD BE THE
BASIC ELEMENT FOR
RECONCILIATION.
AND HE WAS VERY ADAMANT THAT
APARTHEID WAS NOT FOR HIM A
CRIME AGAINST HUMANITY.
AND AN APOLOGY WAS NOT
NECESSARY.
THERE'S RESISTANCE WHEN IT WAS
VERY UPSETTING FOR BLACK SOUTH
AFRICANS.
AND IT REALLY WAS AN OBSTACLE
FOR LONG SUSTAINABLE AND DEEP IT
RECONCILIATION BETWEEN BLACK AND
WHITE SOUTH AFRICANS.
AND OF COURSE, SOME OF THAT
CHANGES, HIS APOLOGY JUST BEFORE
HE DIED IT, I THINK WOULD HELP
TO RESTORE THAT MANY PEOPLE AND
THE YOUNGER GENERATION AND BLACK
SOUTH AFRICANS WHO WOULD BE VERY
ANGRY.
AND TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE HURT OF
APARTHEID.
IT WAS UNDERSTANDINGLY ANGRY.
I THINK IT WILL HAVE TO EASE AND
IT WILL HELP WITH THE HEALING
GOING FORWAR